yeah clearly I'm the target audience of
this film so let's review it
Barbie
[Music]
but Robbie Ryan Gosling directed by
Greta Gerwig and it's based on Barbie
everything's going fine in Barbie land
things start to go awry and that
adventure takes her and Ken into our
world she enters the real world so it's
a whole it's that kind of I thought the
beginning of this movie like the first
half hour I thought it was it was
interesting if not visually compelling
it did look like a Barbie world come to
life they have some fun with some of the
tropes of the Barbie world some of the
cliches Barbie land felt like an episode
of tales from the trip but not the scary
ones you know the fun ones at first it's
a little jarring but you kind of do fall
into it now is Barbie a smash the
patriarchy feminist film yes it is it's
worth addressing it it's in the makeup
of the film to its core to the bone
marrow of the film reviewing Barbie and
not even addressing that fact it's kind
of like reviewing Oppenheimer not even
mentioning the bomb how is the movie
good or bad here's the thing if you do
what I do if you review movies the dude
next to me the movie got over he
literally looked at me he goes good luck
reviewing that but I know something he
doesn't know there are ways you can
preface bullet points as it were things
you can say to soften the internet blows
things like look this movie wasn't made
for me or one that's derivative I'm
obviously not the target audience for
this a solid seven percent of the time
those work 100 of the time all that said
how was the movie I was meh about it as
much as the introduction I thought was
nice and clever I thought okay we're
gonna get some pop culture movie
references wrapped into a Barbie package
of sorts the first 20 minutes or so it
was actually falling into this whole
Barbie land Acid Trip fever dream that I
was in by the end the movie felt like it
had too much going on in it maybe it's
because it really felt like it wanted to
hammer home the message but the movie
just felt too crowded you know you have
Will Ferrell and his crew of Suits it
would have been fine if it was one
boardroom scene with them but they just
kind of are dragged along to the end of
the movie you forget about them that it
reminds you you they're kind of trailing
along you're like oh yeah them then you
forget about them again it'll show them
again just felt like the movie had
reshoots and Pickups or they were like
we did not film enough with Will Ferrell
let's let's have a minute more but you
already had enough going on in Barbie
land you didn't need Will Ferrell in it
that much and that's an example I'll use
where the movie didn't know where the
cartoon ended like when you're in Barbie
land it kind of feels like a cartoon it
feels surreal then they get to the real
world and it feels like the real world
but Will Ferrell and his crew when
they're chasing after Barbie they feel
like cartoons and no not in that way of
cartoonish CEO and his cartoonish suits
created Barbie land which is a
cartoonish place so it kind of makes
sense no it just feels tonally uneven
Margot Robbie was great as Barbie she's
great in that way you know she's gonna
be great from the announcement of Margot
Robbie being live action Barbie I think
we were all like that makes sense she is
a live-action Barbie but Ryan Gosling is
Ken he was a standout in here I was glad
this movie got to show his comedic side
we've seen his comedic side before
absolutely but he was perfect as this
just
well he was just Ken then he was douche
Ken and he makes all of it work the most
I laughed in the movie was specifically
when Ryan Gosling was doing stuff rest
of the time of crickets from me and the
rest of the audience it's fun at times
there's clearly talented Direction and
art Direction behind the camera also
talent in front of the camera but the
cast is too packed some characters feel
like props but you're dealing with dolls
so maybe it's supposed to make sense
like that there was a mother-daughter
dynamic in here that worked by the ends
when I say by the end because the road
to getting there was a bit of a grind
because the daughter was a really Broody
grumpy angry tween for most the film but
all in all there were too many irons in
the fire too many characters to care
about I don't necessarily even think
alcohol is what you need but there's
definitely something you can take that
can Aid in the experience
[Music]
but this movie does Hammer home the
point of its message that message is a
man shall have the power to take over
the world the moment he stops
pathetically simping for that girl he
has no shot with
oh that's not supposed to be the
takeaway all right so Barbie have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]